ladies and gentlemen this is borderlands
3.
now
[Applause]
morning everyone
welcome to the borderlands 3 gameplay
reveal event
please welcome to the stage borderlands
3 creative director paul sage
[Applause]
and please welcome to the stage gearbox
software founder me
randy
how's it going you guys
thank you for joining us here in
hollywood california as we share
borderlands 3 gameplay for the very
first time
it's hard to believe that 10 years ago
borderlands ushered in the shooter
looter i mean and here we are we're
about here to experience borderlands 3
it's been about five years since the
gearbox software development team
started working on this game and we are
so excited to be here to share it with
you today
now
i know everybody's used to hearing me
and randy speak on behalf of the team
today
i'd like to introduce you to some of the
rest of the talent behind
borderlands
the borderlands 3 team you guys
oh
[Music]
thank you guys
these developers on stage include people
that have been with borderlands from the
very beginning when we first created the
shooter looter genre and there are many
folks lots of great talent that's joined
with us along the way and all of us here
have been working together with our
peers back at gearbox frisco hq and
gearbox studio quebec and we are
thrilled to be here to finally share our
work if you've ever enjoyed a
borderlands game or if you're looking
forward to borderlands 3 if you'll
indulge me one more time show this team
show this talent what you think
thank you guys
all right we're going to say goodbye to
the team for now they're going to be
joining us again in a bit because each
of you are going to have an opportunity
later to go hands-on with borderlands 3
and this team we're all going to be with
you helping you out uh so thank you guys
hey uh jeremy dequan can you guys hang
behind and stay play the game jeremy and
jaquan are gonna be uh they're gonna be
playing
right here uh i'm not sure if you guys
have been to an event like this before
but all of this is made possible because
of our publishing partner 2k games and
they've had support from our hardware
technology partner amd powered by ryzen
and radeon and we have incredibly badass
amd hardware there powered by ryzen and
radeon and paul and i wanted to put that
amd hardware to the test with a
powerpoint
so
can we start the presentation yeah
so uh we've prepared a presentation on
what the next borderlands game will be
you're looking at an engine rendered
image from the very beginning of
borderlands 3.
look at the environment it's pandora
the art the style the goal was to try to
create an image that was fresh but also
familiar we wanted to look forward and
taking full advantage of today's
technology in a way that respects that
one-of-a-kind art direction known
throughout the video game world as the
borderlands art style
okay let's be honest this isn't an
actual screenshot from the game
what you're looking at is the game
[Applause]
now
we've skipped past the logos and a lot
of the introductions because we felt
that the most honest way to bring the
game to you today was to start from the
very beginning
so with that let's play some borderlands
3.
hey you must be the new recruit i am a
cl4p
stewardbot but you can just call me
general claptrap of the crimson raiders
what's your name
amara
thanks i'll pre-order your tombstone
just in case now those jerks who tried
to murder you are the children of the
fault abandoned cult who follow their
creepy leaders with blind devotions
which reminds me if you're going to obey
my every second call you'll need an echo
device
try it out i rinsed it off myself
the echo 3 slightly more powerful than
the fo2 and twice as expensive besides
the echo 2 had a tiny issue with
spontaneous combustion so they rebranded
those as grenades
now listen up recruit lilith ordered us
to take over a children of the bulk
propaganda center time to show those
culti weirdos that no one messes with
the crimson raiders follow me recruit to
glory
so lilith's ordered us to take over the
recruitment center of the children of
the vault in the introduction that we
skipped you would learn that the
children of the vault is a new cult
that's emerged on pandora
siren lilith and the crimson raiders are
recruiting new vault hunters that's you
that's us and we are to investigate the
children of the vault cult and discover
who their mysterious leaders are
before we wreak our righteous vengeance
you'll need to register your echo at
this quick change
once we defeat the cult i'll be famous
and when i'm signing autographs i need
you looking sharp while defending me
from my legions of fans stalkers
alright now as you can see here we're
playing as amara and she's a powerful
siren warrior and like claptrap
mentioned we're in the quick change
where it's up to you how you want your
character to look so you can change
amara and change your emotes obviously
okay all right let's keep playing for
now guys
don't worry corporations have our best
interests at heart
except dog
and
hyperion and
the propaganda center is this way
a locked gate no this can't be happening
the entire mission is ruined
think claptrap think you're brave and
powerful and people always do it you
tell them to
that's it
recruit get that date open that's an
order from your superior officer
so obviously you're getting a glimpse
here on how we use the beginning of the
game to make sure players are up to
speed on how first person video games
work we can validate that players
understand how to navigate the
environment and interact with it
we'll even be able to know that a
player's learned how to crouch
and how to slide
you got to make sure you can jump
and if you miss that you can mantel up
and climb the higher ledges
[Applause]
raiders left and right they totally suck
skag balls but i've got a foolproof plan
to kick their culty asses
so as with most games we're begin using
the beginning to make sure that we teach
the fundamentals we're also setting the
tone of the game right just like our
unique art style we want people to feel
right away what we believe helps to make
borderlands special a style of writing
that's both irreverent and genuine
i hit a weapons cache nearby stay quiet
and follow my every move it's downtown
[Applause]
perfect once we complete our mission
lilith has to promote me to super
so we're throwing stealth out the window
relax on pandora it's actually super
weird if something's not exploding
now take your gun recruit you're gonna
need it
these guns like myself aren't beholden
to their primary function i can dance
and sing
and some guns now include an alternate
shooting mode try it out
follow me recruit
all right so as claptrap just mentioned
in order to stay competitive some of our
gun manufacturers have added alternate
firing modes and if we look here we can
see that we have a vlad off pistol and
if we just fire regularly we just fire
bullets
but if we switch our alternate firing
modes we fire off micro missiles
now later in the game you'll find guns
that can switch between ice bullets and
fire bullets or you might find guns that
have a chain gun on top but when you
switch firing modes it'll shoot out
grenades it gets pretty crazy and then
players who maximize all firing modes
will have like twice the guns available
than they had to start with
wait here i'll talk my way in become
their king and then you'll surprise
slaughter them in cold blood watch and
learn recruit
hello
anyone
there influencer of the children of the
vault what do you want crabbot hello
bloodthirsty maniac it is on claptrap
slayer of the destroyer and super
general of the crips and raiders we have
you completely surrounded open the gates
now and perhaps i will be merciful
let me think about that they might call
themselves children of the vault but
they're still bandits and bandits aren't
readily stupid
okay we're going to surrender please
don't kill us grandpa
that's what i thought open the doors
immediately for your new
king i'm a coming out just wait right
there
we did it
i did it another victory for the crimson
raiders
hey i feel funny
what's happening to me
see the degrading cover
oh
[Applause]
borderlands 3 is rated m for mature
right
i'm
[Music]
i know claptrap can be a little
claptrap but he's still one of us we're
gonna have to save him i'll be there
soon
so let's uh let's see if we can find
some loot i saw
over near that door i saw a red chest it
looks like a trunk of a car
[Music]
what do we got here what else is there
oh that's interesting all right so we
can see that this weapon has high
accuracy higher handling
let's look at the other one
all right and this weapon has higher
damage and a higher reload time so it's
either finesse or brute force in this
case so what do you guys think should we
uh shoot from the hip or should we go
with that badass scope
i think i think you guys said scope but
i heard so you know what take both of
them we'll try the scope and then we'll
switch
oh that's pretty badass
these are like level one guns
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
oil's
and delicate flammable can survive a
showdown with shiv unprotected
okay we need a shield this is an area
mission so if we look around we should
be able to find some somewhere
not in the skag pile dequan you on this
all
right that looks promising
oh there we go 77
105 that's better take that one
now you're
chimp from killing invincible in one hit
now let's keep you in there recruit
hey
all your dumb friends are dead i
challenge you to a trial boy combat
but because i'm stuck to this magnet my
loyal champion shall they push you in my
stead
come on in heretick
i haven't made my sacrifice good off for
the day
so i know you guys are getting ahead of
me you can know what's coming next this
is uh this is our first mini boss fight
dequan you ready
we're flying without a net here no god
mode so let's do it
[Music]
nice
oh god
[Applause]
oh my god
oh that was awesome one for the crimson
raiders you and claptrap secure the area
i'm on my way this game's dynamic so
it's like different every time they play
it that was like the best kill ever i'm
glad you guys got to see that
oh
are you dead if not get me down the
controls are on the second floor
now you'll notice that dequan picked up
the shotgun that shiv dropped we think
it's really important that your moment
of victory
should be
have a subsequent reward to it right at
that moment so of course you can pick up
gear right away
all right dude dequan has the same
affliction i have where you have to open
every single freaking chest uh this is a
demo we can just yeah all right
it's so attempting those green lights
oh he's claptrap nagging at us already
so it's not a borderlands game of course
unless claptrap jumps between being
needy and bossy and just pathetic i
don't know how you guys feel about him
but i still kind of love claptrap so
let's help him out
in borderlands 3 you can revive npcs and
npcs can revive you
let's help out claptrap
focus
wow i did it i single-handedly took on
the cov and set the packet now all
that's left is to signal lilith that the
mission is complete
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
[Applause]
willa i can safely report that operation
trojan contract as a complete success i
did it all by myself
well the cults destroyed every other
crimson raider stronghold so this'll
have to do for now
so what's your name killer
i am amara nice tattoo siren sister you
must be the voice in my head
yeah about that not the weirdest thing
you're gonna see on pandora but
seriously thanks for answering my call
we might not have the numbers but with a
badass like you we've got a fighting
chance welcome to the crimson raiders
hey do you hear bloodthirsty screaming
more clv let's see what you got
recruited
chili recipes
eat them
she's pretty rough
so
we're going to skip ahead for a minute
but i want you to consider what we've
learned so far you're a new vault hunter
and you've just joined lilith and the
crimson raiders our enemies on pandora
are a fanatical cult called the children
of the vault and from here you and
lilith will fight side by side to
capture their recruitment center where
lilith believes that she can recover a
key that will lead her to find vaults on
other worlds
the hunt will eventually lead us here to
the holy broadcast center where a
fearsome powerful bandit boss named
mouthpiece broadcasts propaganda to the
children of the vault all over pandora
we're here to invade the holy
recruitment center face mouthpiece and
liberate the key to the vaults
okay so like randy just mentioned we've
skipped ahead in this story but if
you'll notice we've also skipped ahead
in levels so i want to take the time to
show you the skill trees in borderlands
3.
all right
so when you first get your skills in
borderlands 3 you don't just have one
action skill available to you you have
all three action skills available to you
at the the moment you open it up so then
what you do is you equip one of your
action skills so we want to take a look
at the action skills
so this first one
is phase grasp
now phase grasp will be reminiscent of
maya in that she'll be able to control
the battlefield by lifting enemies up
into the air
the next one here is face cast with face
cast she'll shoot out a spectral form of
herself to kill enemies on the
battlefield
and finally we have face slam now face
slam is an area of effect that comes out
around amara and destroys enemies and
knocks them back so
now as you progress once you've picked
your action skill and equipped it you'll
also open up augmentations that allow
you to further customize that action
skill so there's a way to maximize the
build of your character we've worked
hard to make sure that each of our four
characters is completely unique but even
within each character there are hundreds
of meaningful options if two people want
to team up and play the same character
they will very likely have completely
different capabilities
you ready to go let's do it
i was very lucky
now one thing to look out for
is to look at the damage numbers that
come up off the enemies here so
we'll use some of that information later
but just for now like look at some of
these numbers like 56 26
26 is there
oh
now that's a hyperion shotgun hyperion
shotguns have shields that come out you
want to switch back to that shotgun
so great
[Music]
it's a new elemental type radiation
guy hit critical mass
if a radiated enemy dies he'll explode
and
radiate the enemies around him
okay
that's mayhem all right i think you
cleaned this area up let's see what kind
of loot we can find
it's an outhouse but it's got a green
light
some good stuff okay let's see here so
amara's level five these weapons are
level five uh i want you to notice that
by the way notice the two here we've got
a rare and an epic both level five
uh and the reason why i want you to
remember that is because that was kind
of a challenging fight we're going to
need some help for the next section so
we're going to bring in a co-op buddy
borderlands 3 of course is fully co-op
playable split-screen network however
you like to play amara just picked up
the purple turn around and let's look
and find our co-op buddy this is zayn
flint the operative say hi zane
all right we're gonna switch to zane's
view can we flip that now okay this is
zane's view i want you to notice
something here zayn is level 25.
so obviously zane's been playing longer
than amara who was level five
and if we look at zayn's loot
he's got his own instance of loot what's
going on here this is called loot
instancing it's a new optional feature
in borderlands 3 and it allows each
cooperative player to have their own
instance of loot
instance loot is helpful for players
that want to play cooperatively but
don't want to compete for the loot that
drops there's nothing worse than when
you're getting online with randoms and
there's a loot ninja in the group right
so
instance loot solves that problem for
players that want to use it
the other feature that complements this
is uh level balancing notice how zane's
loot is not only instanced but it's
actually balanced for his level that
means the loot the enemies
everything automatically balances to the
level of the player so that everyone has
a good time in my co-op group some of us
would get ahead of the others right and
then when we come back together we'd be
out of whack well with instant salute
and this mode of gameplay everything
balances out now
that's okay you can collapse you'd like
now there's still some of us who
actually like competing for loot are
bringing in overpowered characters to
help you know level up those lower level
characters and for those of you who are
like that we can assure you that there
is still a mode for you in borderlands 3
it's called classic mode
that's right
now that we've seen zayn the operative
let's have a look at what he can do
since zayn is level 25 we've already
equipped a lot of action skills and our
skill points here you want to walk us
through this paul yeah let's do this all
right so the first skill we have is
digit clone now digiclone is really cool
because it not only acts as a decoy it
will actually shoot guns as well
but probably my favorite feature is the
fact that you can teleport to your
digiclone at any time and swap places
this next ability is called the sentinel
now the sentinel is an autonomous drone
that will fly out to enemies and weaken
those enemies or even use your grenades
if you have grenade mods equipped
and then we have the barrier skill now
zane will throw out a barrier in front
of and it'll block incoming bullets and
things like that but of course one of
the coolest features is that if your
team or zane are around this barrier
sometimes it'll confer benefits like
healing or even if you fire through it
it'll add elemental types to that now
probably my favorite feature of zane is
the fact that zane can use two action
skills at one time
that's right and if you think about it
if you think about zayn right like he's
got his uh barrier which is kind of like
the soldier classes capability with that
turret he's got the sentinel which is
you know almost like mordecai's blood
wing but a little hyped up from that
he's got uh the digiclone which is kind
of like our assassin skill from
borderlands 2. he's kind of like a
soldier a hunter and an assassin all
wrapped up in one
all right we've got amara we've got zane
uh we know what they can do let's uh
let's get into the holy broadcast center
and see if we can find mouthpiece
oopsie looks like we've got a
technical issue but don't worry we'll
post the welcome vid later along with
some new let's plays signing off for now
don't forget to like follow and obey
another perfect live stream from our
infallible god queen tyreene
the holy broadcast center opens once
again to hear your sins and receive your
skins
[Music]
ouch
also check out his damage numbers right
his enemies are level 27 but his damage
is balanced to amara's game because he's
in tomorrow's game right now
for amara those enemies are level five
[Music]
all right we clean this area up let's
see if we can find some loot
okay now
once again being honest you know to show
the breadth of guns that we have in the
game or just some of the bread we
cheated a little bit and added some
chests with some better weapons that red
chest isn't going to be in the game you
play we just added that for this purpose
because it's okay there's plenty of red
chests you guys will be fine
we'll feed you baby baby birds that's
cool
we wanted to show you some uh some td or
guns right because you remember tdr
they're disposable instead of reloading
them you throw them away and when you
throw away a tdr gun in borderlands 3
some crazy [ __ ] can happen uh we've got
you know guns with legs
[Music]
let's uh let's see some other options
what does this one do
all right we've just picked up a few tdr
weapons let's take him into the next
fight
go just ignore that green on the ground
there
we're just not gonna learn are we we're
just gonna keep eating those speakers
[Applause]
oh it's adorable
you can see that when merv's rockets out
yeah throw another one of those merv
guns out check this out
all right you guys ready
[Applause]
oh you learned
[Music]
we can dodge that
that's wicked
i see some ammunition vending machines
hey walk up to that ammo vending machine
i want to show you guys this
now he's already full on ammo but you
just press that or press y right there
and you can reload all your ammo you
don't even have to go in and buy things
one at a time
of course you can buy individual pieces
if you want uh now i don't know about
you guys but whenever you play a video
game and you happen upon a room where
there's ammo and vending machines to
kind of make sure you're stocked up it
can be a pretty safe bet that you're
about to run into a boss fight not only
is borderlands 3 a much much larger game
than any borderlands game before it but
we've added more boss fights than ever
before because we think boss fights are
exciting opportunities for players to
have their skill tested but also to be
rewarded with kick-ass loot so let's go
ahead and see if we can find mouthpiece
all right
[Music]
you
well
[Applause]
[Applause]
teleport to dodge that area of effect
that his mouthpiece just made
is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
did you guys see the gun that mouthpiece
was shooting at us with the like kind of
sound waves flying out
check this out
[Applause]
one of the greatest feelings in
borderlands is when an enemy is using a
gun against you you kill that guy and
then you take that gun and use it
against your next pose i love that so
much yeah well let's do what we came
here for and let's get the ball met
amara are you going to pick that up
did you come all this way for that
busted ass map are you just here to see
me didn't know you were such a super fan
well you missed the show oh right but
you're all like what's up with those
husks well it's a thing i do check out
the screens
so i offered the sun smashes a place in
our family but they just wanted guns and
cash they betrayed the family oh then
trey said something great gods
don't
negotiate gods don't negotiate i love it
love it
like i said that map is super busted so
go ahead and take it i'll swing by later
to pick it up you're my most loyal
follower of all thief you just don't
know it yet
so you've just met troy and tyrine
calypso the calypso twins we learned
earlier that on pandora there's a cult
called the children of the vault and
every cult needs leaders this cult is
led by the calypso twins and they've
sort of built a cult of personality
around themselves right
you guys know the type of streamers
we're talking about you know the kind of
streamers everybody hates so these are
like the douchiest kind of streamers of
the impossible future that you can
possibly imagine
as tyreene demonstrated she has the
ability to leech power from any living
thing and her aim is to use her cult to
lead her to the vaults so that she can
soak up the power of the vault monsters
of course we're vault hunters we can't
allow her to beat us to the prize so
with a vault map in hand we're now in a
race to find the vaults hidden on other
worlds throughout the galaxy in other
words
when we go to those other worlds
we're going to need a ride right
so later in our venture on pandora we're
going to find a spaceship
[Applause]
i'd like to introduce sanctuary three
we don't talk about sanctuary too
since sanctuary three is our home base
it's a great stopping point between
missions on sanctuary three we can meet
our friends trade our loot and prepare
ourselves for what comes next
you'll notice here there's a quick
change station where we can modify our
appearance but there's a new vending
machine here on the right
this is sort of a space lost and found
have you guys ever lost loot in
borderlands like a purple or a legendary
lands in some place we can't reach
we collect all that loss for you it lost
loot and we'll deliver it here for you
you'll never lose loot again
all right so let's talk about this this
is your player quarters now because
we're playing amara right now all of the
decoration everything is built around
tomorrow but you can see that you can
place items that you find in the world
like this gun
all right we got a torque pistol here
it's pretty rad but again you can modify
your player quarters to how you want to
play
since we picked up a pistol uh we'll
take it with us on a tour around
sanctuary and why don't we stop first
let's head over to marcus just keep
going ignore that golden chest
marcus's uh place is right around the
corner here
it's a beautiful day full of opportunity
now borderlands 3 marcus will be our
vendor for upgrades to our storage deck
unit right so we can get more storage to
carry more loot and more ammunition
you'll notice that it costs cash to
upgrade your storage stack
marcus also has a shooting range back
there so if you want to get your skills
up practice with any
interesting new guns you found you can
do that
we're just going to take a look around
this place
isn't that cool this map has changed
more hands than any other content in
borderlands 3. we've had so many of our
uh talented world builders want to get
get their hands on this and make it
great
it's not a pub until you have a moxie's
bar right
look at you
[Music]
the name's moxie what's your sugar
thanks for the help sugar
come back
let's try it yeah
all right
oh that's not good oh
bad luck
well thanks for encouraging that
let's keep going on the two all right
i love sanctuary i mean it's just such a
beautiful i don't know the level i
didn't work on this one that much i just
kind of helped guide some of it but the
guys that work but did the art for this
just it's absolutely stunning
these are the jokes
knock knock
anyone home
that's the moment
almost there
[Music]
surprisingly comfortable you know
like a fleshy sleeping bag although i do
feel a bit viscous
so tennis is back
let's uh let's go head up to the bridge
all right
hey uh
hey paul yes randy what can we do on the
bridge
so for the first time ever
we can leave the pandoran system
you can see pandora in there in the
distance
what's up killer
all right let's get to it
we're in orbit around pandora right now
we'll check it out briefly before we
take off you can see its distinctive
iridium scar
but with a spaceship like sanctuary
three we can visit other worlds
now this is early in the game so we
haven't unlocked a lot of the other
places that you will get to explore but
for now we're going to do interstellar
fast travel to promethea
[Applause]
we're gonna go down to promethean a
moment check it out we'll have to make
our way to the docking bay in order to
do that
in borderlands you'll be able to go back
and forth between promethea and pandora
and all of the other worlds that you
discover throughout the game
you might even find a few uh familiar
faces here
what's up badass
[Applause]
i love maya's look she's fully jedi'd
out
we'll take a couple other stops on the
way down to the hangar before we head to
promethia
continue our tour of sanctuary three
oh yeah let's go to hammerlocks
now here in hammerlocks one of the cool
things is hammerlock asks you to kill
different creatures and this is a trophy
room for killing those creatures
oh it's you
apologies it's dark and i've never
actually cleaned this monocle
you can see right now all of the the
trophy mounts on the wall are empty
which means that we've got work to do
right a lot of work to do
now here in the ship you can see we have
shortcuts built in
the more time you spend on promethea the
more familiar you'll get with it we've
kind of engineered some shortcuts and
other ways to get around so you can find
what you need pretty quickly how's your
day going
[Applause]
hey there sugar boobs
ellie's sort of our ship mechanic and
she
she runs the cargo bag
down here we can check out vehicles
we've collected
we can also get access to the planets
when we're in orbit
we've also got some stowaways we can
meet
what you want
[Applause]
come back never
i think his uh vending machine there's a
veteran on it
don't look at me like that i'm doing all
the wheel work here
i don't
uh and he locked us out i think he's
building a girlfriend
i can't believe that claptrap's lonely
it's just hard to believe
so we're gonna head to the drop pod here
this will help us get down to promethea
in fact
why don't we just skip ahead a little
bit uh rather than start at the
beginning of promethea we can jump
forward a bunch of levels and i want to
show you some pretty exciting action
here
in the lore prometheus is the
headquarters of the atlas corporation
and you'll notice as we proceed that
atlas is actually under siege by
maliawan and their private army you see
in borderlands in this universe when a
corporation attempts a hostile takeover
they do it with full military-grade
force
now before we start i want you to take a
look at the gun we're using here this is
an atlas pistol
now
the cool thing about an atlas pistol is
it has an all-fire mode that fires out a
tracking dart and when you fire the
tracking dart it marks a target and then
every bullet that you fire subsequently
will hit that target it's like the fifth
element gun
finally
so uh let me introduce our demoists uh
we've got chris uh chris is playing as
zane uh and uh zane's gonna be our co-op
buddy this time uh and paul is playing
as amara which is what's on screen for
us to watch you'll notice amara and zayn
are both at level 10. and uh we've
actually set them up with microphones so
that we can listen in on their chatter
as they play paul chris you guys ready
i'm good
all right so uh let's uh let's watch
this is the world's first borderlands 3
co-op live stream
take it away paul and chris
after you all right i'm going in
[Music]
there's a bunch of enemies over here i'm
gonna head on the right side and try and
split them up
all right i see a couple behind cover
i'm gonna just pop a tracker
[Applause]
switching overnight
melting on shield switching to fire good
ground slam yeah he's down one on the
left still
warp anchors in got a few more i'm just
gonna ring grenades on the crowd
nice
that weapons depot's a juicy target but
they've got an impenetrable security
force field surrounding it if you
somehow crack it open you're gonna find
some quality firepower in there
so you've just heard from lorelei she's
an all-new npc
we skipped past her introduction since
we skipped ahead and we skipped also a
lot of her storyline but trust that
you'll be able to meet and spend a lot
of time with lorelei and other npcs as
you explore promethea and the other
worlds of borderlands 3. you guys ready
to finish the fight let's go do it
i'm going to run right all right i'm
gonna throw down the shield
cool
it's gonna swing into the shield
taking out shield for you
yeah
picking it up
switching to corrosion for this
all right we got a big crowd on the left
here get a switch to the shotgun
flash trooper go for the pack
i got this guy
got two more over here nice
last one
he's done
nice
i see a chest back here
let's see what you get
all right one i can't use one i can got
a torque
got a bunch of light off pistols
that level 12's a little lp but you guys
can save it
oh delayed fire mode
that's cool ready to move on all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
thank you guys
wow
i don't know if anybody got that math
joke divide by zero but they got it
we're nervous you know what are you
gonna do
look we can't wait for you guys to play
this massive game for yourselves and to
discover what other surprises and
characters and loot and plot twists and
everything there is to experience and
explore in borderlands 3.
so today
based on the time we have we've just
been able to show you just a tiny
fraction of the game and so
with that i think what we want to show
is just a little bit more of the breath
that we have so we prepared a trailer
for you here
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
thank you guys
thank you
wow
oh wow thank you guys
oh man
oh wow yeah i don't think we've ever
shown this much of a gearbox game before
or just just soon after announcing it
frankly uh the fact is we've never had
this much time to finish and polish a
gearbox game before so we're feeling
really good about the position we're in
and excited to bring borderlands 3 to
the world
as you can plainly see we've made a
commitment to what borderlands is
supposed to be we've made a commitment
to the story the style and the design
that our fans have told us loud and
clear that they cherish and want us to
preserve in borderlands 3. you know it's
it's an interesting time in games right
now there's all kinds of people making
all kinds of money doing all kinds of
interesting stuff out there we just love
video games we think video games are
supposed to be fun and we love
borderlands so we wanted to make sure
that we were true to what it is and if
you want to play offline we've got you
if you want to play online of course all
the co-op modes you expect are there uh
yeah we're going to do some kick-ass
campaign dlc and i'm sure we're going to
do all kinds of fun customizations like
heads and skins but we're not doing any
of that free to play junk there's not
going to be any micro transactions
there's not going to be any of that
nonsense
and if you've played a borderlands game
before we expect you to feel right at
home but we've made sure to design
borderlands 3 in the story and in the
gameplay and everything such that this
is the perfect entry point for any gamer
that's going to be experiencing
borderlands for the very first time when
borderlands 3 launches on september 13th
and what you've seen today so far it's
really just scratching the surface
borderlands 3 is massive it is by far
the largest borderlands game we've ever
made and we've just had an hour to touch
a couple things near the beginning of
the game working closely with our
publishing partner 2k games you can
expect to see more and more of
borderlands 3 through the summer up
until the launch on september 13th we're
planning to share more and more of the
game at upcoming shows right we're going
to be at e3 we're going to go to
gamescom in germany we're going to go to
the penny arcade expo of course we're
going to hit a few other things we're
even going to crash guardian con in
orlando
so that should be fun and uh we're not
even finished today
in this room with us we've brought 200
amd powered machines where you guys are
all gonna have a chance to play
borderlands through yourselves
it's going to be an unguided experience
we're going to just drop you in
prometheus do whatever you want mainline
quests side quests
just free play right we're going to give
you 90 minutes and i know all of you
guys are going to be streaming to all
your followers so
have fun we want you to have a blast
with it if you're watching them on
twitch if you're watching these guys
play on twitch be sure to take advantage
of the custom borderlands 3 twitch
extension that we've created at gearbox
uh you can link it to your shift account
so that you can start collecting
borderlands 3 loot today and that's
going to be waiting for you when the
game launches on september 13th
now it's gonna take paul and the rest of
the gearbox guys a few minutes uh to get
everybody set up on the stations over
there
so uh paul's gonna get going on that and
uh i'm just i'm just so glad that we're
here today and that we can do this
um thank you guys so much uh by the way
uh while they're setting up fortunately
we've got the folks from kind of funny
here they've seen borderlands 3 for the
first time here at this event so i'm
going to say goodbye tomorrow to now for
now and we're going to kick it over to
greg and andrea and fran and they're
going to share their thoughts about
borderlands 3 for everybody watching
at home and thank you guys so much for
coming here and being with us
i'll see you soon
cheers